mortgage rates continue to be at an
all-time low so is now a good time to
refinance
rocky spoke to clark county credit union
to get the answers
ryan welcome to the show thanks for
having me rocky
absolutely okay so we're talking about
refinancing mortgages
is it still a good time to do that it's
still a great time to do that
rates are at an all-time low and uh
homeowners can stand to save a
significant amount by refinancing now
um online site nerd wallet said that 17
percent of uh homeowners
refinanced in 2020 and they're
estimating 31
of homeowners were refinanced in 2021 so
definitely still a good time
okay and let's go over the benefits of
refinancing right now
i mean the biggest benefit of course is
monthly savings uh you know if you can
lower your rate
you can you know reduce your monthly
payment save a significant amount of
interest or the life of your loan
possibly pull cash out
drop mortgage insurance all sorts of
benefits okay
and what should you consider before
refinancing your home or there is there
something that you should make sure is
in place first
sure yeah definitely i mean the things
you want to look to when you're
considering refinancing
is you know what is your current rate
what's your monthly payment
um possibly even loan term maybe you
want to cut from a 30 year to a 15 or 20
year
and of course is there a possibility to
cash out to do any of the projects you
might be considering
and of course as you mentioned savings
are really important in this process so
is there a way for
applicants to learn how much they can
save before they turn in their paperwork
to refinance or
definitely definitely the the place to
probably start is to go on to our
website
ccculv.org and on there we have some
calculators that can help
you know uh homeowners figure out
whether refinancing will save them some
money
all they basically need to have is their
uh you know monthly payment
their current interest rate um the
current balance on their loan
and that'll let them get started if they
have more questions they can reach out
to one of the loan officers here at
clark county credit union we can go over
their particular scenario for them
perfect you guys always have great
resources for everything financial
um and what about credit how does
refinancing your home affect your credit
uh you know credit's always vital when
you're refinancing or you know getting
any type of loan
um you know there are sources that you
can use even online where you can
check your credit um as for foreign
mortgage loan will require to pull
all three bureaus so a lot of times it's
good to check with you know the credit
union
a loan officer first get an idea of what
we might be looking at in terms of
credit
and how that's going to affect your loan
your refinance those kind of things
all right well thank you so much ryan
great information awesome thanks for
having me
call clark county credit union at
702-228-2228
or visit ccculv.org las vegas